faute de pouvoir traiter le sida un peu
d'eau mois essayait de le prévenir il
existe pour cela des précautions fort
simple comme l'utilisation de
préservatifs voilà pourquoi la
secrétaire d'état à la santé michèle
barzach a décidé d'autoriser la
publicité sur les préservatifs ce qui
serait déjà un élément d'information est
une façon peut-être de lever une forme
de tabou en france anne rogère a demandé
son avis à un publicitaire
jacques séguéla vous avez obtenu à prix
pour cette publicité diffusée en
belgique parce que là bas la publicité
pour les préservatifs est autorisée est
ce que c'est un produit comme les autres
donc pas tout à fait comme les autres
mais la publicité et celle des autres
s'est il n'ya pas de sot métier il n'ya
pas de sots produits d'ailleurs pour moi
il ya une règle de communication qui
s'applique aussi bien le président de la
république car le préservatif c'est la
règle et les 3r le rêve le rire et le
risque alors est ce qui est le principal
obstacle pour vous en france ça ne va
pas être de lutter contre la culpabilité
rampante
oui j'ai vu une étude ces derniers jours
qui disait que les hommes avaient encore
honte de demander un préservatif dans
une pharmacie fier parce que j'ai été
pharmacien avant d'être publicitaires et
les gens de métier des petits mots les
hommes en me disant préservatif alors
qu'une femme entre dans une pharmacie a
dit donnez moi des pilules et bien la
publicité va en fait déculpabiliser le
consommateur il n'y a pas de honte à
mette un préservatif je vois vraiment
pas en quoi c'est plus ridicule que de
mettre mais perméable
voilà le préservatif c'est l'imperméable
du sexe